gentlemen friends this is not a test
easy menswear collection by Kanye West
it is here we have every single piece in
the collection seen here for the first
time since the fashion show there's been
a lot of controversy about it a lot of
fighting online in the GQ office
everywhere so Jim what do you think the
most successful aspect of it is I think
the fact that you can buy a Kanye's
closet this is what a designer does you
know they use themselves as a muse and
they make clothes that they want to put
on their backs let's talk a little bit
about what we've seen from Kayne at past
GQ shoots well we were shooting him we
would put you know classic sweatshirt on
him right and the first thing he would
do is just like rip out the neck yeah
stretch out the bottom and pull it down
to his knees nothing can be long enough
nothing can be stretched out it right it
was this whole kind of relaxed slouchy
but controlled relaxed and I think
that's what he's done here he's really
giving you one of the secrets to his
great taste can I put you on the spot
Jim Moore yeah sure your five favorite
pieces right here right now
definitely the sweatpant ez is in the
details these like hidden zippers here
look at the culture customizable yeah
cuff number two the camo hooded m65
jacket I mean it's incredibly modernized
it's a very subtle very wearable camo
again I think what's great about is the
colors are so dusted it's really is like
the dopest dustiest army-navy store I've
ever robbed
I'm crazy about this jacket and
basically it's part of the parka and
it's a flight jacket but everything has
been super-sized they found the hungry
coyote you can cut it they head number
four is this military sweater this is
based on an authentic army sweater
obviously it's oversized it's already
peeled and it looks like it's a little
bit not at yeah and that's what gives it
its nice texture they [ __ ] them up
that's the only way to put it
I'm just crazy about these boots I'm
calling him the blizzard boots
he's completely modernized a classic
silhouettes and made it his own I love
the colors that come in this kind of
like warm brown and you know the really
chunky thick sole you need something at
the bot the base that can handle all
that volume right and this is the way to
Cris is the way to do it love it or hate
it
feel free to argue it out and think
whatever you want but the fact is Connie
has done something different here he's
got something to say as a designer the
best part is going to be where does it
go from here
you